First up, we all love to pamper our animals, clearly
but Travel + Leisure
reports that you can now check in your dog,
your little fur muffin,
into the first ever luxury hotel for dogs.
It's called Urban Mutt in London's West End.
It's like Soho House for your dogs, darling.
(Ross laughing)
It costs $200 to join
and then you can sign your fancy fur ball
up for fitness classes, spa treatments,
or an overnight stay in an indoor sleep hub
with mood lighting and room service.
Doggy acupuncture, massage and Reiki,
they're all on the spa menu.
Ross, would you check those chihuhuas in?
(Ross laughing)
I am actually really impressed with you,
just side note.
I would bring my dogs there.
I have to say, they're not spoiled necessarily.
(Drew laughing)
At least that's what I thought to myself.
But then I was thinking about massage for dogs.
And then I remembered I one time had a massage therapist
come over to massage one of my dogs
because she had little legs issues
and she had surgery
and I thought I was worried that she was sore.
And so it turns out these crazy people
that spend this money on their dogs,
hi, I think I'm them.
(Drew and Ross laughing)
You know what?
I need to check myself into this hotel.
(Ross laughing)
That's what I just surmised your story, Ross.
(audience clapping)
Save her a spot at the doggy hotel.
All right.
Next, I know we all want to support
our favorite local restaurants
and give them a chance to thrive again, right?
Well, a writer at Food & Wine
has a great suggestion on how to do that.
Try an early bird dinner,
making a dinner reservation for 5:00 or 5:30
helps restaurants fit in more seating every night
'cause they have a ton of demand
for that 7:30 sort of prime time spot.
So why not take an early spot and beat the crowds
while helping your favorite spots fill their seats?
Now, I do this because I live my life
like an active senior citizen.
(audience laughing)
I like, I do.
I wake up early.
I love a 5:30 dinner reservation 'cause then by 7:00,
I'm home in elastic watching 90 Day Fiancé
like a normal person.
(audience laughing)
This is not a joke.
Do you like early dinner?
I think basically,
and it's funny
'cause my sister, Jill Kargman.
Yes?
Literally, everything is on the later side for her.
And she won't bend, too.
She knows very much like what I like and what I don't like.
And a lot of people really think
that dinner is between 7:00 and 8:00
and then goes to like 9:00, 10:00, 11:00.
I can't do it.
If it's too late, I'm just not in.
It's like, I'm so tired by that time
then I'm just resenting the people.
Oh, God .
I've become bitter.
Yah.
(audience laughing)
It just happened officially.
(Ross laughing)
No, I don't get the late dinner thing.
No, because then I haven't eaten
till I get there at 7:00 PM.
And when I see you,
I'm like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's get appetizers. I don't want to talk to you yet."
Because I'm starving by that point.
Do you wanna know what I really hate, Ross?
No.
Coffee at the end of the dinner.
I'm like.
(audience laughing)
I have to sit there and watch you drink that.
(Ross laughing)
Gosh darn it!
So you had appetizer,
you've had dinner, you've had dessert.
And you're like, "Okay, I'm gonna get out of here."
And they're like, "Do you have any cappuccino?"
(audience laughing)
Yes!
And I'm like, "Why are you drinking coffee
at night, anyway?
What's wrong with you?"
That's a good 30, 35 minutes
you're sitting there or more.
I gotta sit here and make chit-chat
while you caffeine up at 10:00 PM.
10:00 PM?
God!
It's just like I'd realized at that moment,
we have nothing in common.
(Drew laughing)
No, it's just.
I'm sorry, but this is just not gonna work.
(Ross laughing)
But you and me Ross we'll do early bird special.
No coffee.
Are you nuts?
(Drew laughing)
No coffee. No, I gotta go home by 6:39.
I want you to look at my face
when people order coffee.
Yah, here, let's try it.
Ready?
Um, can I get a coffee?
Look at her.
(Ross laughing)
(audience laughing)
(Drew laughing)
All right, Ross.
Now I know you love to get down and dirty with a stain.
(groaning) Not as much as you do,
but I do love getting to clean.
Okay, well, I am so excited about this
because if you are into stain removal,
well then you are, for Ross and I,
we'll see you at dinner at 5:30.
(Ross laughing)
Yahoo Life reports that TikToK is freaking out
over this stain removal.
Okay, it's the powers of something called The Pink Stuff.
#pinkstuff has over 57,000,000 views
and people say it can remove any stain from any surface.
Yah.
And it's only $10 on Amazon.
There's nothing's ever turned you on
more than this, has it?
(audience laughing)
You love a stain remover.
I'm so hot right now.
(Ross laughing)
It's like you could go to Thunder from Down Under
or Magic Mike.
(Ross laughing)
I wanna stick ones in this.
The Pink Stuff.
I do.
I wanna stick single dollar bills
in the G string of The Pink Stuff.
I was trying the whole time you were talking
to get it open and I still can't do it.
By the way, 'cause I realized it's right here.
Understood.
(Drew and Ross laughing)
I think I...
(Drew and audience laughing)
(Ross laughing)
Okay, first of all.
Oh, that's delightful.
Yeah, it doesn't smell like very chemical at all.
It smells like taffy.
We have a stain right here.
I'm also disappointed by this challenge.
I'm not gonna lie.
You guys have got to give me like tar on a white tank top
But hold on.
This could be baked in by the sun.
This could be impossible to get off.
Are you excited by that?
You know what?
I am just feeling like maybe
that I wouldn't mind a tougher challenge.
How about you?
You think this is too easy to get off.
Way!
So what do you wanna do? You wanna try something harder?
Yeah, I was thinking maybe we could do something
like get multiple surfaces and stains
that are really challenging
and put this 57,000,000 views and counting.
Mm hm.
New revolutionary stain removal available
at Amazon for $10.
(Ross giggling)
And literally the thing people are freaking out over.
People put it in their car cup holders.
Apparently, you can clean steel with it.
Oh, really?
So I'd really like to put it to the test.
Are you going to think about this all night long?
(Drew giggling)
(Ross laughing)
Yes.
When I go to bed at night, yep.
Of course.
(Ross laughing)
When most people are entering the restaurant.
(upbeat music)